the number one reason brother that most
people here will not scale to the level
that they want to is cuz they don't love
their employees enough the real answer
to the quiz is realizing you work for
people not they're beholden to you cuz
you write their check the way that
employers treat employees when they have
big aspirations and it's their company
I'm not talking middle management in a
corporation you're both in jail
I'm talking it's your and you want
it to be as big as possible the two
biggest mistakes people make is they
don't invest in people like really for
example I have 2,000 employees I got a
ton of going on and yet if you
looked at my calendar I'll show you
right now watch this tomorrow I promise
you like no forget that don't look
at how many it's what it's what in these
15minute meetings it's with employe page
oneon-one right Charles one onone yeah
one-onone one on1 15 minutes 15 minutes
15 minutes you just don't care
about them enough attention is the
number one
asset